uh welcome to Hannity hope you had a
great fourth with you and your family
and tonight shocking news developments
uh in the highly unusual Federal probe
into Hunter Biden uh that did more to
protect the Biden family than actually
investigate any potential real crimes
also tonight Sarah Carter she will join
us with more on today's San Francisco's
reparations panel where one member
accused straight white men of being
serial killers also more racist attacks
from the left against Justice Clarence
Thomas now Casey DeSantis uh it seems
like if you're an African-American
conservative or the wife of a prominent
conservative uh well you can be called
any name in today's woke World why is
that but first let's check in with your
commander-in-chief Joe now this was Joe
over the weekend now watch this closely
here he was on a very crowded Beach in
Delaware of course he has this expensive
home on a senator's salary on the beach
she struggling look at him struggle here
to try and move a beach chair that
probably weighs all of two pounds and
take it a few feet and and then look at
the sitting it's not exactly very
comfortable is he going to make it is it
going to tip over good Joey very good
anyway uh tough couple of days for your
president now earlier in the week the
administration was reeling after a bag
of cocaine was actually found in a
secure area of the West Wing So far what
eight days in it's a total mystery who
brought the cocaine into the Biden White
House hmm I know where my mind goes that
would be a normal thought process but
you're not allowed to talk about it
whatever you do don't dare suggest that
the former crack cocaine Head Hunter
Biden could be a suspect that's a No-No
forget the pictures of videos of Hunter
smoking crack and sleeping see she's
dead asleep and that that's a crack pipe
right in his mouth and forget that he
was forced to replace all all of his
teeth with veneers and I don't have a
problem with that because of what they
call cracked mouth that destroys your
teeth when you're a heavy crack user now
of course so far press secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre has refused to rule out any
member of the Biden family but she did
call reporters he said she said they're
irresponsible for daring to ask
questions about the cocaine take a look
can we just say once and for all whether
or not the cocaine belonged to the Biden
family so
a couple of things there we've answered
this question litigated this question
for the last two days exhaustively
um you know there has been some
irresponsible reporting about the family
and uh and so I gotta call that out here
and I have been very clear I was clear
two days ago when talking about this
over and over again as I wasn't being
asked a question as you know in media
Outlets reported this the buying family
was not here they were not here
they were at Camp David they were not
here Friday they were not here Saturday
they were not here Sunday they were not
even here Monday they came back on
Tuesday so to ask that question is
actually incredibly irresponsible
and and um
I'll just leave it there
no Corrine it's incredibly irresponsible
for you to lie to the American people uh
and say that they were not in the white
house on Friday when they didn't leave
till late Friday night we still do not
know who brought the hard Co drugs
cocaine into the Biden white house uh
and uh was it laced with fentanyl is
anyone asking that question and why have
they not found the person or persons
responsible I would think in that
environment with all the Secret Service
that that would not be the most
difficult task for a smart detective and
keep in mind Joe and Hunter were both
there on Friday evening or at least
until Friday evening in spite of Korean
lying to the American people saying that
they were not there on Friday when in
fact they were now before the misplaced
bag of cocaine was found over the
weekend what kjp is getting noticeably
frustrated and angry for good reason her
friends in the media mob they're not
quite as accommodating to the bidens
these days in fact many of Biden's most
reliable left-wing allies are turning on
him interestingly they're all doing it
at the same time let's take a look at
the Atlantic quote step aside Joe the
president has no business running for
office at the age of 80. axios referred
to Joe As Old Yeller in a report about
how vicious his quick temper is that is
and it's so bad that aides avoid meeting
with them one-on-one they even bring in
support help if they need it anyway very
common condition for older people by the
way in steep cognitive decline they
often go hand in hand meanwhile an op-ed
in the hill openly wondered quote when
is the optimal time for Biden to drop
out of the race and then poor
congresswoman Alexandria ocasio-cortez
blasted by members of her own party
after she endorsed Biden for a second
term why because the rest of her party
don't want him even the United Auto
Workers Union they're now refusing to
endorse Biden at least for now because
of his obsession with green energy and
electric cars and last but certainly not
least liberal columnist Maureen Dowd New
York Times staple of the democratic
party's media apparatus apparatus
dropped the hammer on Joe Biden in a New
York Times op-ed entitled it's seven
grandkids Mr President by the way
Maureen if you've watched the show more
often you would have known about this a
long time ago during the article doubt
is recounting a letter from her Biden
loving sister to the president that
reads in par quote I watched as you told
the nation that you had six
grandchildren and you loved each one of
them you also claimed that he talked to
them daily I believe that what I cannot
believe and what I find unconscionable
is that you refuse to admit or accept
the fact that there is a beautiful
little four-year-old girl living in
Arkansas by the name of Navy Joan who is
your seventh grandchild down then
continues quote the president's cold
shoulder and heart is counter to every
message he's trying to send or Ascent
for decades keep in mind Maureen Dowd
defended Bill and Hillary Clinton and
pretty much every other prominent
Democrat that was faced with any Scandal
over the years so this is interesting
isn't it when you have people like
Maureen Dowd and many other reliable
Democrats and left-wing journalists
turning on Biden and those that support
him are getting excoriated by their own
party right now as the presidential
election is heating up do you find the
timing odd the answer is written on the
wall they want both Joe and Kamala out
of office mark my words and are now
working to replace them at the top of
the ticket behind the scenes before it's
too late don't forget both Joe and
Kamala have historically bad poll
numbers the economies of shambles world
affairs are an absolute unmitigated mess
most Americans don't even believe Biden
is capable of serving a second term
which brings us back to the video of
Biden struggling on that crowded Beach
to even move a beach chair while
everyone pretty much ignores him compare
that to Donald Trump he was in Vegas
over the weekend at the UFC fight where
he was warmly greeted by pretty much
everybody in the crowd friends
supporters even sometime critic Joe
Rogan got in on the action shaking his
hand everyone in attendance was excited
to see him Democrats they were extremely
worried about that quote enthusiasm Gap
no one is excited to see Joe Biden why
should you be he is a massive liability
anybody with eyes to see can see it make
no mistake Evan newsom's Countrywide
tour that's not a sightseeing Adventure
that's not I really think Joe is a great
president Adventure either he's ready
he's willing he's able to step in and
it's probably probably only a matter of
time now my belief has been and remains
he is being called and begged daily by
prominent Democrats all around the
country to jump in this race that means
jump over and replace Kamala Harris in
terms of who would be the natural
successor hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else